okay so today we we will finish the
Greeks um by discussing
Aristotle and a lot of what I will say
today um will be
controversial okay so um feel free to
challenge me feel free to ask for
clarification feel free
to um ask any questions okay so um
here's my argument Aristotle is a
paradox he is one of the mysterious
figures in world history he's one of the
most famous but he's one of the most
most mysterious he's a paradox for three
reasons
okay the first reason is he is
considered to be one of the greatest
philosophers in human history he's next
to Plato he's certainly um as
influential as
Plato but what is unique about him is we
do not have anything originally written
by him okay we have no text that we
believe was personally written by him
and that's unique in human history okay
we say Shakespeare was a great writer
and we can prove it or show it by
reading his
text We Believe Aristotle is a great
thinker a great writer but we have no
evidence no text to show us this is the
case we but we believe so okay so this
is the first paradox of
Aristotle second Paradox of Aristotle
is he was a very prolific writer and
thinker in fact we believe he um there's
about 200 Works attributed to Aristotle
what is unique about his work is the
range of his thinking and his research
so he's written uh a book on politics
right what is the best political system
he's written a book on uh Poetics
theater basically what makes for a good
tragedy he's written uh a book on ethics
what is a good life what makes a good
person he's written a book on rhetoric
how do you convince the audience that
you are correct he's also written books
on physics he's written books on
metaphysics he's written books on on
biology okay it's the range is just
incredible we have no analog in human
history like him okay he's completely
unique in the range of his uh curiosity
okay second
Paradox the third Paradox is most
problematic okay we know that Aristotle
studied under Plato for 20
years and so we also believe that AR AO
was
Plato's uh most famous
student the Paradox is Aristotle
Aristotle's understanding of the
universe is radically opposed to Plato's
understanding of the universe okay and
that's again is unique in human history
you would think the best student would
carry on the Master's work or at least
build on it right but Aristotle his
understanding of the universe is in
conflict with Plato's work in fact you
could also argue that Aristotle is
negating Plato's worldview okay so let
me explain how so we know Plato we know
that for Plato there is a God and it's
called the form of the
good and the form of the good is what is
Eternal
perfect and immutable okay now the form
of good
emanates um other Perfections okay what
he
calls the form of the ideal okay so
these are Concepts like justice and
beauty and reason and then these
Concepts manifest themselves in um
forms like horse right or a woman okay
and these are like the ideal perfect
immutable
Eternal um
manifestations okay so there's only one
horse it's up in heaven everything else
is a copy of this horse or imitation of
this horse okay so we live in the shadow
realm okay the shadow realm where
everything is imitation okay this is our
reality it's a shadow
reality and that's why art and poetry
and theater are so bad because they are
really an
imitation of an imitation okay so this
is um Plato's hierarchy so from this
hierarchy and this worldview we can make
certain extrapolations okay the first
extrapolation is for Plato what is good
is if you approach or return to the form
of the good what is evil what is bad is
if you move away from the form of the
good
okay right so poetry is
evil um mathematics is good okay now why
is mathematics good because mathematics
is what allows you
to approach the form of the good all
right so let me give you an example of
this okay let's see there's a circle
right now what PL argues is
no matter how hard you try you could
never ever draw a
circle in this world okay because a
circle has an edge so it's like
literally impossible for you to create
something without an edge right you're
like well I can draw on the computer but
if you go at a microscopic level you
will always find an edge okay so how do
you create a circle well you create a
circle by imagine it in your head okay
so by what you're really doing is you're
Imagining the circle because you're
accessing the realm of the forms you're
approaching from the good okay so it's
only pure it is only through a process
of pure thought pure philosophy pure
mathematics that you can actually um
start to understand this
world all
right that's Plato's understanding of
the world ER arle has a completely
different understanding okay so arle
starts with this the God is a prime
mover so the prime mover just imagine a
big bag right something explodes boom it
moves and it forces other things to move
as well so what Aristotle is saying is
everything is really in motion okay
everything is
change because it was all caused by the
prime mover
and in Plato and sorry in Aristotle's
world what is good is if the thing that
changes moves towards its purpose okay
or the word he uses is called TS
TS okay if you're moving towards your
purpose you are doing good in this world
if you're moving away from your purpose
you're doing bad in this world okay so
the example is a soldier the purpose of
a soldier is to fight and win Wars so if
you go fight and you do your best you're
doing good but if you run away from a
war you're doing bad
okay so um this is
Aristotle's worldview and as as you can
understand as you can see these two
worldviews cannot harmonize they are in
conflict with each other you're have
either one or the other okay so let me
highlight the three major differences
between these two
worldviews okay and again um I I need to
emphasize this I am not an expert on
Aristotle I'm not an expert on Plato
okay so I am committing
oversimplifications Scholars who are
experts will hear this and be outraged
okay but for the purpose of this class I
feel these
oversimplifications uh provide Clarity
okay all right so the first over simpli
ification is PL is what we call
irrationalist um is what we call an
emperis all right so these are two big
words um but the rationalist is just
someone who believes that you can access
the truth through pure thought okay
mathematics and empiricist is someone
who believes you can only access the
truth for observation and what we call
induction okay inductive logic
all right so if I see a woman wearing a
dress and I see another woman wearing a
dress and a third I'm like okay well
from this I
can um logically deduce or induce that
all women wear dresses and that's what
separates women from men okay so um for
Aristotle to seek the truth you have to
observe and you have to uh induce okay
so that's the first major difference
second major difference is Plato is what
we called
dualist and Aros is what called
materialist a dualist is someone who
believes that there's a body and a soul
okay and if you believe there's a body
and a soul you also believe the soul is
more important because the soul is
eternal whereas the body will Decay and
die um
Aristotle he's materialist so for him
the focus is on the body and what
happens to the body okay there may be a
soul uh there may not be a soul he
doesn't really care for him it doesn't
really matter what matters is what
happens to the body Okay the third major
difference is Plato believes in the idea
of immutability okay or what we call
eternity um for
Aristotle
um almost nothing is immutable most
things are mutable okay the only that's
really IM mutable is really God but
everything else is mutable it will
change over time and so for Aristotle
the concept is infinity okay things will
always change things will always move
there's no stopping movement
okay but for Plato things are Eternal
there's there's a grand design and
nothing that changes really matters it
doesn't really affect the Grand Design
so for him it's eternity okay so these
are the three
major differences between Plato and
Aristotle now what's really interesting
for us is this conflict between PL and
Aristotle is what will inform the
philosophical debate for all Western
Civilization okay so there are two major
camps in Western philosophy there is the
rationalist camp all right so people
like decart and then there are the
emperis okay so people like David Hume
all right and for most of Western
history um philosophers will go back and
for between these two uh extremes okay
either plat platonic ideal or theal
reality okay does that make sense all
right is this clear any
questions sure go
ahead
y IM
yeah so that's a great question and for
Plato okay all what we like our lives
the reality we live in is not real it's
Emeral whereas the form the good that's
what's concrete that's what's Eternal
okay so I mean like I I understand
that's counterintuitive to us but the
reason why it's counterintuitive to to
to us is because we're mainly influenced
by Aristotle right we live we we are
materialists right science is
materialistic uh but back then and and I
I would say um back then in Plato's time
and for most of human history it was
assumed um that our world was transitory
or transient or ephemeral okay and it
was a spirit world okay that was
real and that was
eternal okay does that make sense
okay okay again this is
oversimplification okay like if you go
to a scol who understands itself I will
probably he'll probably criticize me
okay but I I'm saying that for the
purpose of this class and for our
understanding of Western Civilization
this will do okay just understand
there's a major conflict between C and
Aristotle this will go on for thousands
of years this will
inform uh the debate in western
civilization okay this is the
fundamental debate in Western philosophy
right
so let's go back to Let's summarize
where we
are um Aristotle is a paradox right we
have nothing that he wrote
originally uh the range of his work is
just
incredible it's Unique in human history
and then lastly even though we know
Aristotle under Plato for like 20 years
at least um arot came up with a very
different conceptualization of the
universe in fact it is in direct
conflict
with Plato's
understanding okay so how is this
possible how are these Paradox how can
we resolve these
paradoxes okay so um I'm going to make
an
argument and I will slowly make this
argument but it is a controversial
argument okay my argument is that
Aristotle was not a philosopher he was
not a thinker he was not a writer what
he was ultimately is is what I refer to
as a
sensor sensor you can also use words
like sympathizer okay or
editor or systemizer okay but basically
um nothing that he thought was original
to him but he
decided what would be political
convenient for the moment okay that's
what we mean by
sensor and it's my argument that if we
understand a as a sensor then these
three paradoxes go away we can explain
away these
paradoxes all right so let me make my
argument okay my first my first piece of
evidence
is
um we need to compare contrast the life
of phac
Mason and Aristotle when you do that
okay when you put their Liv side by side
interesting
parallels emerge okay so let's look at
their lives very simple Aristotle he was
born in year
384 Philip II was born year 383 that's
about the same age
right now Phil the second he's a prince
of Mason his father is the King right
Aristotle his father was the court
physician to the king he was the king's
personal
doctor right
so from these two pieces of information
what can we guess about Philip and
ariso they go up together right does
that make sense aros's father was the
personal doctor of the King Philip was
the son of the king it would make sense
they grew up together it would make
sense they would be educated
together all
right second thing that's interesting is
from 367 to 3 348 okay
Aristotle went to Athens to study in
Plato now around the same time okay in
the year 369 to 365 Philip went to
thieves to study military Innovation
under the best jours in Greece all right
and here I would extrapolate and say the
their
teenagers they're going to further their
education
right and learn the best scientific and
Military innovation in order to bring
back to
Macedon and this happens all the time
right in the 1980s China sent its best
and brightest to America to study
science
okay so we can also surmise that even
while they were away they were still in
contact with each other all right
now in
359 Philip became Regent or basically
King and from then on he started this
massive military campaign to conquer all
of Greece
now one thing that was interesting about
Phil's conquest of Greece
was the Athenians didn't really oppose
him okay and this is one of the great
Mysteries historians struggle with why
is it that Philip II he's going around
he's conquering all these um places that
are um in conflict with Athens and
Athens doesn't really resist all right
and one possible theory is well Philip
II just bribe all these Athenian
Aristocrats in fact um the man who most
opposed philli um this Athenian
Statesman named deanes he actually said
this in speeches he said listen
uh um I'm telling you right now Philip
tried to bribe
me okay and I know Philip is bribing all
my opponents but I'm telling you
Athenians Philip is a menace to
democracy and that's why we must oppose
him all right so we can surmise that
Philip was bribing these Athenians to
support him and that's why there's so
little Athenian
resistance to Philip if that's the case
then who's the middleman who's the
person who's in contact with these
Athenian
Aristocrats Aristotle right why because
remember Aristotle was at the Academy
for 20 years the academy in Athens at
that time is like Harvard Oxford today
right it's where all the rich and
Powerful go to study so for 20 years
Aristotle was in contact and became
friends with the most powerful
individuals in Athens and that's why
when Philip need to negotiate with
Athenians it would make the most sense
to say to send Aristotle okay does that
make
sense and then we know that um
Philip United Greece in 338 and then 335
three years later um Aristotle started a
new school in Athens in competition
Academy called the the lysium okay so
what is the purpose of the lysia okay so
um that's what I will discuss next but
but does does that make sense there are
direct parallels between the lives of
Aristotle and Philip and we can guess or
extrap
um or deduce that a St and Philip were
very close through throughout their
lives and helping and they were helping
each other okay does that make sense
okay so now the question then is why was
Philip going around conquering all of
Greece well Philip had a vision for the
world and it's called something called
we call the pan helenic
project okay so panh helenic project
okay so um at this time and throughout
most of its history Greece was divided
into city states all around the world
okay mainly in Main in Greece but also
across the asan in Asia Minor in Asia
Minor Anatolia okay um across all these
different islands and into North Africa
and
across um the Adriatic also into um
Italy as well okay so you have this
sprawling Greek world
and there were many who believe that
this Greek World should unite together
because there's a common
ancestry all right so it's a dream of
many philosophers that a great man of
History would arise and unite all of
Greece by basically defeating
Persia and Philip second said hey that's
a great idea and it should be me
okay but the problem is
is the Panic project um assumes a common
Greek identity and it didn't really
exist at that time in fact Greeks
probably had more common with their
local cultures than with each other
right so if you were a Greek living in
Asia Minor you were probably more
Persian than you were
Greek okay so in other words Philip
needed someone a sensor basically to
create a Greek
identity right and the way you do that
is by taking all this vast Universe of
knowledge that the Greeks created right
and you create an encyclopedia or a
series of textbooks that Define what it
means to be
Greek right you standardize and you
systemize Greek
knowledge does that make sense and so
that's probably what aristot was doing
when he started the uh
Lum he had lots of
students
okay yeah so throughout history all
Congress did this okay because that was
the only because by standardizing and
systemizing knowledge was the um best
way for you to Coop the leite the elite
and to Showcase your your legitimacy
okay otherwise intellectual Elite would
think of you as a barbarian conqueror
all right and the the way the best way
that you uh coopt the intellectual Elite
is
by um
showcasing uh uh a new systematic
knowledge okay does that make sense all
right so
um the problem is that in
336 um Philip was assassinated and his
son Alexander came came to a throne came
to the throne and as we discussed last
class
Alexander had a very different vision
from his father his father want want to
unite the Greek World alexand wanted to
conquer the entire world to show he was
Superior to his
father okay and unbelievably incredibly
he was able to do so conquer most of the
world in about 10 years time so now
suddenly you have have this sprawling
Empire all around the world okay so
let's let's let's just sketch out how
vast this new Empire was okay so you
have you know Greece and
massalon right okay so that's the Greek
Homeland thank
you that's the Greek Homeland right but
hey over here you have
Anatolia uh this is mess tenia over here
is um
Afghanistan oh sorry sorry it's it
should be Iran sorry Iran Afghanistan
and you also reach as far as Pakistan
okay and down here you have the
lvat and you have
Egypt all right this was not supposed to
happen philli and the Panic project in
Imagine like their Conquest would extend
up to up around here okay your United
Greek World Alexander went too
far and now you're you've conquered most
of the Known World
okay then Alexander died and then the
empire was divided into three major
fragments over here you have something
called the ingate Empire okay the ingate
dynasty okay so that's one piece of the
Empire down here you have t
okay Tomy was one of Alexander's
generals and he took over Egypt and over
here you have something call the cusd
Empire founded of course by the general
uh sucas okay and over here you have
other smaller kingdoms as well so you
have this
vast Empire and this is something that
was unplanned and
unexpected now
that you've conquered these places your
concern or your problem is how do we
govern okay so you need a new
culture and so these different generals
adopted different strategies so for
example um here um the Persian culture
is extremely well established and the
soloed uh King and his hearers decided a
process
of localization okay or another word you
can use is
synchronization synchonization
okay meaning two different religions or
two different cultures come together and
coales together okay so uh throughout
the saluan Empire it was really a
process of
synchronization um the Greeks adapted
themselves to local customs and to local
culture okay at the same time the Greeks
were
conquerors so they still need to
maintain a coherent
identity okay so it made sense for them
to adopt a lot of Aristotle's work
because remember Aristotle was creating
a the a panh helenic identity and so he
he basically created a lot of textbooks
he basically um created an encyclopedia
so it made sense for them to import um
Aristotle's works also it's important is
remember aristot
was
Macedonian and for the longest time
Greeks did not considered macedonians to
be
Greek okay this is why it's called the
panh helenic project not not like the
pan Greek
project also Greeks um were very
condescending towards macedonians
because they saw macedonians as
barbarians so it was in the best
interest of these new ason conquerors to
exaggerate or to highlight the
intellectual contributions of Aristotle
okay does that make sense
right um colomy Egypt was very
different okay Egyptian culture has been
around for thousands of years and
Egyptians are very
proud of their culture and this is a
problem because you're very proud of
your local culture you don't like
foreign rulers and this is something
that the Persian Empire struggled with
throughout the um centuries that it
dominated Egypt okay um the Persians
were famous for their openness and
tolerance basically you were allowed to
practice your own religion and they're
very supportive of that okay um the most
famous example are the Jews right who uh
the Persians supported in rebuilding the
second temple we we'll get to the Jews
later
on um but because the Persians were so
supportive of local culture in Egypt the
Egyptians rebelled against Persia many
many times so Tommy and his hearers
didn't want to make the same mistake
okay they wanted to impose a new culture
on the Egyptians in order to show that
they were Superior and therefore more
Divine than Egyptians okay so T me he
did many things that start this process
the first thing that he did was he stole
aer's body from Babylon where he died
and brought it back to Egypt okay
because Egyptians saw exander as a God
as a son of a God right so to establish
legitimacy in Egypt Tomy went on a mil
military Expedition and stole the body
of Alexander which started something
called um the war of the diai okay
basically the successor
Wars that's the first thing he did so
thing that he did was he established a
new capital in Alexandria called
Alexandria okay so this was um mainly a
Greek city it was a new Greek city
founded by
Alexander and that this is where they
house Alexander's
body the third thing that he did was he
started to to sponsor something call we
call the uh today the musion okay the
Mion um is the root of the of the
English word m Museum but the museon was
really the world's first research
University so Tommy and his heers
brought together the greatest Greek
scholars in the
world to basically continue the work of
Aristotle to standardize and systemize
Greek culture so that they can impose it
on the local Egyptian culture okay
doesn't make
sense right and uh the most famous um
aspect of the Mion is the Library of
Alexandria and the Tony spent a lot of
money on the Library of Alexandria
mainly by going around and collecting
original manuscripts all right so um a
representative went to Athens and said
we at the library of exandria would like
the original copies the original
manuscripts for Isis sopes and yides the
three great playwrights and the
Athenians are like we can't do that
because they're like Gods here okay
we're not going to give you original
manuscripts and the Egyptians said um
what we're going to do is we're going to
take these manuscripts back to the
Library of Alexandria where our scribes
will copy them out okay oh that's all
we're going to do and then we'll give it
back to you and as as a guarantee we're
going to give you like 15 talents of
silver okay and that's like that's like
a billion dollars back then the athans
have never seen so so much money so
Athenians will say well okay well if
it's just to spread great culture we can
actually deal with that okay so we'll
take the deposit 15 talents we'll give
you the
manuscripts the Egyptians took the
manuscripts placed it in in the Library
of Alexandria and said hey Athenians
keep the money
okay because the Egyptians under Tommy
were focused on turning the Library of
Alexandria and Alexandria into the
intellectual capital of the Greek
world all
right and so what happened was that
after alander died and his generals took
over the Panic project really became
what we call the panh
helenistic
project okay it went from uniting the
Greek world into spreading Greek culture
all around the
world and that's why we have Greek
culture still with us today okay because
of this
process so let's go back to the original
Paradox all
right why there are three paradoxes
right the first Paradox is why do we
have nothing original from from
Aristotle the answer is because
Aristotle didn't write anything original
he stole everything from other
thinkers and students um copied out in
manuscript form okay does that make
sense second is why is his uh why are
his works so diverse why is the range so
great the answer is because he was
trying to capture the essence of Greek
knowledge okay you're trying to
unify Greek knowledge into an an
encyclopedia for discimination around
the world Okay the third thing is okay
most interesting thing
is why is Aristotle's philosophy so
different from
Plato's
worldview okay that's that's that's a
really interesting question why why are
they so
different so let's switch our
perspective and ask ourselves if you
were a king of mascon if you're Philip
Alexander what's your problem with
Plato's
philosophy you have a problem what is it
any
guesses your exander your phow you
really hate ploh
why
why well the problem with Plato is you
go to Plato you're exam you go play says
I want to conquer the world right Plato
would say what's the point it's all not
real
Alexander you're just wasting your time
you can conquer the world but all you're
doing is conquer a shadow what whe is
the form of the good right ask Ender
study mathematics man okay do more
math stop going around and killing
people do more
math right and we know what Alexander
would do here right Alexander would
probably cut off Plato's head so a Phil
hate this thing right this thing is
idiotic I want to talk the world but
this philosophy is telling me it's
pointless what matters is mathematics
what matters is philosophy all right now
let's now
compare um this with Aristotle's
moover Theory right what is saying is
everything is motion and what is good is
if you fulfill your
purpose right now if you're Alexander
Phillip this makes more sense I'm
Phillip my purpose is to unite the Greek
world and the more I unite the more good
I'm doing for this world
right
also if you're a king you want your
citizens your soldiers your workers to
work hard
right well for
Plato working hard is just
useless you're imitating an imitation
right when you when you create
art but
here working hard is what gives you
purpose what it's what gives you
happiness okay
so Aristotle also um promoted two major
Concepts the first is
er second is
udonia okay irate is just
Excellence okay your Xander has ER he is
an excellent
General when you have ER and you are
achieving your purpose then you achieve
udonia okay which is just flourishing or
happiness
and that's the purpose of life to have
ER and to achieve yonia so work hard
okay fight for alander support him as he
conquers the world because he's making
the world better does that make
sense I'm a soldier purp
to am I not
okay that's a great question yeah thanks
Doug okay all right so um the question
then is if I'm a soldier and I'm and I'm
you know working hard and winning
battles am I not approaching from the
good and the answer is for Plato it's
not the reason why is what do you do in
this material world is pointless okay
because this material world it's not not
real so whatever you do is not real does
that make sense okay so what you need to
do is return to the form of the good but
your body can't do that your soul can do
that so your use of the body is
pointless you have to use your soul you
have to use your mind all right
therefore you have to be a good person
therefore you have to engage in
philosophy and Mathematics and that's
how you return to the form of the good
you're Ed to the body um it it's just
you're just in a you're just deluding
yourself okay right and if you engage in
art then you are deluding others and
that's more evil if you're exander
you're conquering others and forcing
them to believe your fake philosophy
then you're committing the most evil in
the world does that make sense all right
all right so um yeah all right so this
this is what I this is my theory of how
to best resolve the three paradoxes of
paradoxes of aristot okay does that make
sense he was basically a censor who is
working for Philip and and
Alexander and he was trying to develop a
panh helenistic identity in order to
unite the world they
conquered okay so that's my argument any
any questions about this overall
argument does it make sense to you
guys okay got a few questions go ahead
yeah thank you right go
ahead that's a great question yeah okay
all right so um how do we know he didn't
write any of his works okay the answer
is this um when you write something you
actually um manifesting your thought
right your thought comes from your
personality so if you look at any work
of Genius it's original and unique okay
does that make sense in other words if
you read Shakespeare guess what there's
no other Shakespeare in the world if
you're trying to imitate shakespare you
look like an idiot okay Homer is unique
Plato is unique this there there's no
point in trying to imitate them you
can't do it because you are not themb
okay now when you look at
Aristotle there's a unique about
Aristotle so um you know when you read
Plato the Republic there are certain
ideas that stand out like um Al go the
cave okay there's certain phrases that
capture your imagination that doesn't
exist with Aristotle's text okay they're
really like textbooks so the argument
for the longest time was um
Aristotle did write his own books but
they were lost to us and his students
had to reassemble his thinking from
their own memory okay um so so so yeah
that's how we know but but this is
generally agreed upon we have nothing
that Aristotle wrote originally
okay that's right
is
that yeah okay so thank you uh Doug okay
yeah so um there are many
different possibilities of how air AO
can become so influential okay the first
possibility is as as I as I argue he was
actually a partner of Phillips that they
were both uh trying to promote the pan
helenic
project okay that's the first
possibility but another possibility is
as Doug says um he was just a
philosopher he was a student of of of
Plato he was very
smart um and he was a very good teacher
and after Alexander and his General
conquered the world they needed like a
symbol of Macedonian cultural
superiority and they just decid upon
Aristotle because it was most
convenient right so that's another
possibility
okay that's
right right
y yep exactly so so yeah so it is
entirely possible
that
Aristotle um was a materialist because
that was just his personality right the
influence from his father who was a
physician okay but but that creates
another problem which is if you are so
opposed to Plato's understanding the
world right because you're a materialist
and he's a dualist why were you studying
under Plato for 20
years does that does that make sense I
so so so so so that creates another
problem all right so another thing I I
want I want to point out is okay H how
we have aerosus works today there are
three different possibilities okay the
first POS possibility is that Aristotle
in his lifetime he organized his
students and created this encyclopedia
okay it's no different from philos from
professors at University toate right
professors um who are scientists they
actually do very little of the original
research they have the students do it
but they ones who supervise the entire
process okay so it's possible uh that's
a first possibility Aristotle was
supervising uh the work of creating a
Greek identity the second possibility is
after aoto died his students started to
um remember recall his lectures and
that's why so much of his work is
fragmentary okay we don't have complete
manuscripts and the third possibility
okay and it's entirely possible is
Aristotle is a fiction created by
Scholars at the library of of exandria
okay so it's really the scholars at the
Library of Alexandria who created
Aristotle and they did so by
synthesizing all this work and then they
they gave it to they accredited it to
attributed to Aristotle in order to
create the legend of this
philosopher okay does that make
sense okay so so so so so so let's have
an argument about confus let's have
discuss about confuses okay but I want
to very quickly talk about the Greek
Legacy because even though uh we can
argue back and forth about Aristotle and
his Providence what is not debatable is
the profound influence that Aristotle
had on the world okay we can argue if
Aristotle's if or Aristotle was um the
original writer or the original thinker
well what is not debatable is the
tremendous influence he had on the
entire world okay so there three aspects
of the Greek Legacy I want to discuss
the first aspect
is um the Greeks created a new way of
Being
Human all right so let's look at the
major thinkers you have
Homer you have the playwrights Isis
sopes and Ides and you have the
philosophers like Plato and
Aristotle all right so the Greeks
created a new way of Being Human what do
I mean by that
Homer was an Oral B okay he would get up
in front of audiences and he would for
hours recite this beautiful poetry about
the Tran War the ilad okay and in the
process listen to Homer created
empathy and
Imagination right because the point
of um listening to Homer was to enter
Homer's world and become Achilles or
adicus and through this process you
became a different person and therefore
you learn empathy but you also expanded
your
imagination okay so that's what that's
what Homer did
for the Greeks then you have ises sopes
and yides and what they did that was
different
is rather than sing directly at the
audience they had the characters face
each other in a dialogue in a debate
okay and by doing this what happens
is you
create the capacity for
perspective and inner debate right
because before you were
part
of the uh story now you have to step
back and judge the story okay you
there's a debate going on you have to
switch perspectives in order to
understand the characters and this
creates the capacity for an in monologue
okay an in debate in
you and then you have Plato and
Aristotle what Plato did that was unique
was he took all the
dialogue in the play and he transported
onto the page but now you're read it by
yourself and you have the benefit of
time okay
and so this creates a capacity for
reason and
reflection okay you can sort of reason
out if the words make sense to you
you're no longer influenced by the crowd
or the emotions of the actor you can
just look at the words themselves and
judge them on their own Merit you also
have the capacity now to reflect meaning
you can go back to the words over and
over the course of your lifetime to
constantly reflect on their meaning and
logic okay you understand so when you
add these three things together Homer
create the capacity for empathy and
Imagination the playright create the
capacity for inner debate and
perspective the philosophers create the
capacity for reason and reflection you
now have a new human mind
okay and when you study all all of them
this is what we call ultimately a
liberal arts
education all right and guess what our
greatest
thinkers came to us through the liberal
arts all right so in the future we'll
study people like Kant Hume hego okay
just the greatest thinkers of the past
20 years they all what was common about
them is they all read the Greeks and now
it's just their
education all right so so this
is the first Legacy of the Greeks a new
way of being and
seeing okay does that make sense second
thing
is now that you have this Greek World
okay the Greeks need to establish a
cohesive cultural
identity and they had they they did that
by promoting a Greek
education okay but not only that but
they had to bring in local people into
this education so one major function of
the Library of Alexandria was to
standardize and systemize Greek
knowledge and they did this by um
standardizing the text okay so there are
different different text of Homer the
the the text of Homer that we have today
was developed by the people at the
library of exandria okay
standardization they also uh did
something called commentaries so
commentaries are basically like teacher
handbooks okay they they teach you how
to teach this
stuff and they created like footnotes
and chapters and page numbers Cotes
indexes okay so um the point was to make
Greek education available and accessible
to
anyone all right and what this means is
we in China now can actually read Homer
uh issist and Plato for ourselves even
though we are not culturally Greek and
and that's the benefit of the panh
helenistic
project all
right and the third major benefit
is Greek knowledge meant a global
revolution in Innovation okay what what
I mean by that is remember Greek
knowledge is being spread all around the
world
and then they're interacting with
powerful local
cultures and through the process of
synchronization new forms of knowledge
are being
created okay so the Greeks uh spread the
knowledge to India and now it's
interacting with local Indian philosophy
and religion including new ideas right
so the most famous synchronization
is um the
Levant Greek knowledge was being spread
to the Jews okay and so when you put the
Greeks in the Jews
together you have a new idea that would
forever revolutionize human history and
it's called
Christianity right so Christianity would
not have been possible if it were not
for um the work of
Aristotle okay right so those are the
three major Legacies
of the Greeks and so it is um I think
it's perfectly fair to say the Greeks
were the most influential and
consequential civilization of all time
they're certainly the most creative no
no other civilization even comes close
to their
creativity
right okay so that's
it any
questions okay so um okay
so we are finished with the Greeks next
class we start a new unit on Rome Roman
history all right so um great